- Is "Jungle Cruise," is
it related to the ride
that my kids and I go on?
- It is based on the ride.
- Okay, my kids are gonna freak out.
They love, that's their one
thing they always want to do.
- It's a great movie.
I'm very proud of it, it's funny.
And it's, I mean, it reminds
me of those great movies
we grew up to, you know,
like Indiana Jones and this
big adventures movies, yeah.
- I love those, Junior, move the chair.
That was like, my favorite line.
That's my Sean Connery, you're welcome.
So, so what is the movie about though?
So I get it that it's about
the ride, but it's something.
- Yeah, I mean, we're like,
a lot of different people
with different intentions
get to the jungle
to try to get something
for different reasons.
- Okay, so it's a little
like "Tomb Raider," too.
- Yeah, exactly.
So we're gonna get something,
I mean, this is spoiler,
you know, spoiler territory.
- Don't spoil it.
- So we're all there to get
something out of the jungle
for different.
- Some of you have good
intentions, some of you had bad.
- Exactly, yeah.
I'm a little bit of both.
So I told you, like good
and naughty, same time.
- Oh my God, it's your theme in life.